(electronic beeps)
(calm music)
- Well increasing evidence suggests
that normal brain development is impaired
in a schizophrenia and other
neuropsychiatric disorders
long before the onset of symptoms.
So emerging genetics and other data
intriguingly have been
implicating immune molecules
and immune related pathways,
raising many questions about
the underlying biology.
So we recently discovered
an unexpected role
for our resident immune
cell called microglia
in this sculpting process,
this pruning process.
And so today I'd like to tell
you about what we've learned
about how it is that these cells
know which synapse to prune
and which synapses perhaps not to prune.
And how our work using mouse models
are providing new biological insight
into this pruning pathway
and how this might go
awry in schizophrenia
and other neuro developmental disorders.
Neuro circuits undergo
tremendous remodeling
during development.
We start out with an excess
of synaptic connections
that are maintained in the mature brain.
And through a developmental
process called pruning,
or synapse elimination,
many of these extra synaptic connections
are permanently removed
while others get
strengthened and maintained.
This concept of use it or lose it.
So this process is of course regulated
and modulated by experience.
And this process, refinement
process, is necessary
for developmental and the precise wiring
of synapses in the brain.
And disruptions in this process of pruning
are thought to underlie neurodevelopmental
and neuropsychiatric disorders.
Now interestingly, there are
different critical periods
of pruning that happen in
different parts of the brain.
And as you heard earlier today,
interestingly, parts of the
brain like the frontal cortex
are the last areas of the brain to prune.
So the big question of course
is what regulates this pruning process?
So a major question in the field
and one that my lab has
been intensely interested in
is understanding how it
is that specific synapses
are eliminated during development.
If we can understand the mechanisms
by which specific synapses
get pruned or vulnerable,
this might provide new insight,
and even therapeutic insight
into how these synapses
get lost and diseased.
So it's well established,
as you heard today,
that neuronal activity
plays a critical role
in refining synapses and
synaptic connections.
So we know, for example,
that activity sets up a local competition.
So if you look at this cartoon here,
you can see that this neuron
is innervated by inputs.
These left and right eye inputs.
If you were to, for
example, label these inputs
in the visual system.
But over the course of development,
you can see that this neuron,
that some of the inputs, in
this case, the blue ones,
get permanently removed
while the red ones get
strengthened and maintained.
So what is the question mark
that we're interested in
is understanding what are the molecules
that link chains in activity
that with a physical
elimination of the blue input
but not the red one.
So much of the field, of course,
is focused on the neurons themselves.
These are, in fact, the
cells that get pruned.
But emerging evidence implicate glia,
the non-neuronal cells of the
brain in this pruning process.
And more recent work have been implicating
these cells called microglia.
Now as a card carrying glial biologist,
I have to say I've ignored
these cells my entire career
until very recently.
And that is in part because
these are the only cells
not born in the brain.
These are our immune cells.
They actually, now we know, reside,
or are originating from the yolk sac.
And they actually enter the brain
very, very early in development.
In fact, in a mouse, they enter the brain
as early as embryonic day eight.
That means they're the first
non-neuronal cell in the brain.
They're there when amazing
growth is happening
in the embryonic brain.
Yet we know surprisingly
little about the normal roles
of these cells.
Much of what we knew about them
was in the context of injury and disease.
Now these cells make up about
10% of the cells of the brain.
They tie all the brain.
But one of the things that
makes them incredibly unique
and different from any other cell
is they're our resident phagocytes.
They're actually, by nature,
the fact that they're immune cells,
they're really good at eating things
or phagocytosing things.
But the other thing
that two photon in vivo
imaging has shown us,
meaning if you were to put a microscope
over a mouse's brain and thin their skull
and use a reporter line
in which all the microglia
are labeled green,
what you can see is that these
cells are incredibly dynamic.
You can see their processes
are constantly moving
all the time.
And they're serving the
extracellular environment.
And the big question we wanted to know
is what is it that they're serving?
And one of the things we now
appreciate that they're serving
are synapses.
So if you were, for
example, to overlay neurons,
in this case, this
neuron is labeled in red,
you can see the processes
of these microglia
intimately contacting spines
and axons all the time.
This is happening in your brain right now.
It's amazing.
And one of the things we also appreciate
from our work and others
is that they can even sense
local changes in neuronal activity.
So if you manipulate that
neuron and you fire it more,
or if you silence it, the
microglia knows somehow.
And that suggests that there
must be some sort of signals
that are being transmitted
and that the microglia have receptors
that recognize those signals.
So what about the postnatal brain
when all of this remarkable
plasticity is happening?
What about early in development?
So that is the question
we set out to address
a number of years ago.
And we use the developing
mouse visual system
as our model because so much was known
about how synapses prune
in this particular part of the brain.
And so we use the developing
retinogeniculate system
of the mouse where you can
actually label the inputs
from the two eyes with a dye.
And then we could ask what
are the microglia doing
at that circuit during the
critical period of pruning?
And what you can see here
is that the microglia in green
are intimately associated
with the left and right eye axons.
And the question that Dory
Shafer in my lab asked was
are they actually engulfing
or eating those synapses?
And what we found is that
almost every microglia
we surveyed during this peak
of remodeling at this point
were full of inputs from
the left and right eye.
They were actually in their lysosomes.
And quite importantly,
this process of pruning
was developmentally regulated.
They were doing it during these
critical periods of pruning
but not later.
And that suggests that
there must be some signals
that tell the microglia to do this
and other signals that
tell the microglia to stop.
And we're very much interested
in understanding what those signals are.
So the next big question of course
is how is it that microglia
know which synapses to prune?
Now, we now appreciate that
it's not a random process.
The first hypothesis is
well, they're phagocytes.
They just happen to be there
and anything that's
around, they're gonna eat.
But we know there are
critical periods, again.
And so that suggested the possibility
that they were recognizing
synapses through some molecules.
So going back to that activity
dependent competition model,
the red and the green,
the red and the blue inputs,
if you change activity,
we know that the less active inputs
are selectively eliminated
or more preferentially eliminated.
And again, using the visual system,
we can manipulate activity in the two eyes
and block activity in one eye with a drug
that blocks sodium
dependent action potentials.
And what we found is that microglia
preferentially engulf the
axons from the less active eye.
And that again tells us
this is some activity dependent cues.
So how do microglia know
which synapse to prune?
Well, recent work,
if we go back to work I did as a post op
in Ben Barres's lab,
back then, we unexpectedly
identified a rule
for a group of immune
molecules called complement
in this process of synaptic pruning
in the mouse visual system.
Now this is a group of immune molecules
traditionally associated with
the innate immune system.
And this was a surprising
finding at the time,
but we essentially found is
that the retinal ganglia cells,
the cells that are
actually getting pruned,
are actually expressing some
of these molecules like C1Q,
and if you knock out
C1Q and downstream C3,
these mice failed to segregate
into their eye specific territories
and they remained multiply
innervate, even into adulthood.
And so this raises question of how is it
that a group of secreted molecules
that are related with the immune system
could be doing something
as precise as pruning?
Well, going back to the immune system
is where we learned a lot.
Complement's main role
in the immune system
is to tag apoptotic cells and
bacteria for rapid removal.
So for example, C1Q would
bind to that bacterial cell.
This would set up a proteolytic cascade
that then cleaves downstream
components like C4, C2, C3.
And the canonical way by which
that cell would get removed
is that it would get tagged by C3
and then a main way it gets removed
is through phagocytes like
macrophages in your periphery
that express receptors for complement.
And what we found is that complement
was actually tagging, if you will,
subsets of synapses during development
and that microglia are the main cells
that express this comp neuron receptor.
And that led to this hypothesis
that microglia were recognizing
complement tag synapses.
Maybe the less active synapses.
And indeed, when we knocked out
either the receptor on the
microglia or complement itself,
microglia are only about half
as good as engulfing synapses.
So this identifies complement
as one of the main ways by
which these synapses get pruned.
But of course that also tells
you it's not the whole story.
Now importantly,
if you fail to prune
through this mechanism,
this leads to sustained defects
in synaptic connectivity.
There were too many synapses.
In fact, David Prince's lab later went on
in the C1Q knock out mice to show
that these mice remain multiply innervated
and hyper connected and they
were more prone to epilepsy.
At least through the adolescent period.
And that of course raises many questions
we're actively investigating
related to the functional
and behavioral consequences
of not enough pruning
or too much pruning during development.
And that now brings me to this question
that this as one of many mechanisms
by which synapses gets
pruned is unexpected
because it involves an immune cell
in a group of these
secreted immune molecules,
but there's many other
lines of evidence now
that are implicating both glia
and other immune molecules
like the MHC and the pure B.
Now importantly, much
like the immune system,
this pruning pathway we've identified
seems to be tightly regulated.
Microglia do not continue
to do this through life.
There are times and places
when which this is happening.
They become less phagocytic
as the animal matures.
And a lot of these molecules like C3
are dramatically down
regulated in the healthy brain.
You'd not want to have pruning
continuing all the time.
But what if it did?
What if it kept pruning
and what if the breaks weren't there?
Or what if something turned
this pathway on too much?
We hypothesize that this
could lead to an excess
or an inappropriate pruning
of either the wrong synapse
or too many synapses.
And this could potentially lead
to some of the pathobiology
underlying neurodevelopmental
and neuropsychiatric disorders
such as schizophrenia.
So this has been the question
that we've been interested
for a very long time.
But of course, as you know,
there are not very many good
animal models of schizophrenia
so it's been a very
hard question to tackle.
Now indeed, several
lines of evidence suggest
that synaptic pruning may
be altered in schizophrenia.
In fact, the pruning hypothesis put forth
by Finder 40 years ago
propose that altered cortical pruning
is critical for
development of the disease.
And indeed, this classic
study by David Lewis's lab
shows very intriguingly, a loss of spines
in the prefrontal cortex
of some individuals
with schizophrenia.
And imaging studies have
also showed cortical thinning
in patients even before
the onset of symptoms.
And putting this together,
the pruning hypothesis
is pretty attractive.
However, it's not actually
been directly demonstrated.
We don't yet know, for
example, in these patients,
were these really a pruning defect?
Were these lost or never formed?
Was this cause or consequence?
And again, this is very
difficult to really tackle
in models because there really aren't
any good animal models.
Well this of course is
where human genetics
can be extremely useful.
And in the next few slides
I'd like to share with you
new and recently published findings
by my colleague Steve McCarroll
and his graduate student Aswin Sekar
who have been using genetics
to identify mechanisms
and novel pathways for treatments.
Now the strongest genetic signal, by far,
has been on chromosome six
in a region known as the MHC locus,
which contains many genes,
many of which relate to the immune system.
But researchers had no idea
which of these many
genes contribute to risk.
Now this region spans hundreds of genes,
many of them, as I said, in
code immune related genes.
But the MHC signal has
really remained unexplained.
And really, it doesn't
follow any mathematical
or statistical patterns explainable
by any one known genetic variance.
So what could be explaining this effect?
Well, intriguingly and
interestingly, within the MHC,
this is one of the strongest risks
for associated with loci near
the gene C4, complement C4.
Which of course is a key part
of the complement cascade
I talked to you about earlier.
Now Aswin honed in on this
for that and other reasons.
And he was also, and Steve's
lab has been interested
in this question of
structural variability.
Why different people
have different numbers
and copies of different genes.
And they developed methods,
molecular techniques to characterize
the C4 gene structure
in human DNA samples.
And quite interestingly, what you'll see
is there are actually
two C4 gene, C4A and C4B.
And unlike most genes,
this gene has a high degree
of structural variability.
Variation.
And what he found is that
some people's genomes
have extra copies of A.
Some have extra copies of B.
Some have completely
lack one or the other.
And this led Aswin to ask
could the structural
form of C4 you inherit,
could this related to the
increased risk of schizophrenia?
Now the challenge was
that although the Aswins
developed these techniques
to measure C4A and B
and the variation in
different individuals,
how do you link this to
schizophrenia risk, right?
So Aswin and Steve developed a novel way
to map how C4 structure
relates to SNPs, right,
or from which genetic data
was already a variable
from tens of thousands of individuals.
They essentially built a map
to infer the four most common forms of C4
from the SNP data surrounding the gene
which essentially created
molecular barcodes
from the SNP patterns.
And it works because humans
share long genomic segments
that they have inherited
from common ancestors.
And this map then allowed
them to take advantage
of SNP data in giant beta
databases from around the world
which essentially turned a
molecular biology problem
into a big data problem.
And here's what they found.
Alleles of C4 appear to shape risk
in proportion to their
effect on C4A expression.
On the left, which you'll see,
is how each alleles here
relates to schizophrenia risk.
And you can see those that have more C4A
have significantly increased risk.
On the right is each allele's affect
on C4A expression in the brain.
They found that C4 gene structure
could predict C4 gene activity.
And notice now that those that have C4A
have more C4A expression.
And together, I know I'm
oversimplifying this story
which has been recently
published earlier this year,
but for now, the
important thing to realize
is the more C4 you make from the locus,
the greater the risk of schizophrenia.
Now that raises a number of questions
that we're now actively investigating.
And we're starting to collaborate
Steve's lab with my lab
and also Micheal Carroll's
lab to ask this question.
How is it that elevated C4A,
how could this contribute to
the risk of schizophrenia?
What is the biology
underlying this risk factor?
Now this brought together my lab,
which has been studying
complement and pruning,
Michael Carroll's lab as an immunologist
who's been studying C4 for his career
and all of our labs
together sort of join forces
in this multidisciplinary collaboration.
And the first thing we did is
we looked at the C4 protein.
And they're actually a pretty good
human antibodies for this.
And we basically asked,
much like we noticed in the mouse,
could C4 be tagging synapses
in the brain of humans?
And we used tissue that was generated
and given to us by the Stanley Collection.
And we looked in these brains and showed
that C4 was, in fact, binding
to subsets of synapses
in the human brain.
In the schizophrenia patients.
And then more over,
Heather de Rivera in Steve McCarroll's lab
grew cortical neurons
and then stained them
after they developed with C4 antibodies
and shown that C4 also binds
to these synaptic structures
in cortical neurons.
And interestingly and importantly,
C4 is actually being made by the neurons
and secreted by these human neurons.
So this is just early data to suggest
that the protein is there
and it's actually binding to synapses,
at least under these conditions.
But of course the big question
is is it related to pruning?
So this is when we again
went back to the mouse.
So we went from human
to mouse in this case
and we asked does C4
mediate synaptic pruning?
And so we went back to our very classic
retinogeniculate system.
We used mice that were
generated by Mike Carroll's lab,
these C4 knockout mice.
And Allison Bialas who was
a graduate student with me
and now a post op with
Mike did this experiment.
Basically did the eye specific segregation
or pruning experiments in C4
knockout mice versus control
and the prediction
would be that lacking C4
would lead to a defect or lack of pruning,
much like we saw in the C1Q and C3 mice.
And that's exactly what we saw.
And interestingly, the
retinoganglian cells
were expressing a lot of C4
during the peak of pruning.
So this is the pre-synaptic neuron.
And mice that lack C4
failed to segregate nicely
into these eye specific territories,
which you can actually label
by tracing the left and
right eye with color toxin
and then doing this thresholding
to show the two eye interactions.
So this told us that lacking
C4 led to failure to prune.
But the big question now moving forward
is could excessive pruning contribute
to the pathobiology of schizophrenia?
Could this relate to
the David Lewis's study?
And so that is actually what we're now,
together as a collaboration,
actively investigating.
Could overactivation of complement
during these critical periods of pruning
contribute to wiring
defects and schizophrenia?
A number of other questions were raised
that we're actively pursuing as well.
And one of the questions
that again stem from
beautiful work presented earlier today.
Could pruning also help us to understand
the age of onset of schizophrenia?
Might pruning become too intense
and prolonged in certain individuals?
Might it expose other
pre-existing vulnerabilities
and how is it that
environment, like stress,
impinges on the genetic pathways like C4?
And we're also wanting to now
move from the visual system
that we love so much into much
more uncharted territories,
which is the prefrontal cortex.
And Mike Carroll is
developing mouse models
to look at over expression
of multiple copies of human C4A in mice
so that we can start to address
some of these questions.
Now I'm just gonna end in my last slide
to try to pull this together.
But also to broaden this a bit more.
The idea that although we've been focused
on neurodevelopmental and
neuropsychiatric disorders,
could this pruning pathway represent
a more general common pathway
that not only might explain
synapse loss during development
but also could it actually
also help to understand
why synapses are vulnerable
in the adult brain,
especially in aging and
neurodegenerative disease
such as Alzheimer's?
And so indeed, multiple
work now from several labs
including our own has suggested
that this very same pruning pathway
that I just told you about
becomes aberrantly activated
very, very early in
Alzheimer's disease models
and other models.
And that indeed, that this overactivation
contributes to synapse loss
and very excitingly, if
you block this pathway,
either genetically or the
antibodies or other mechanisms,
you can prevent synapse loss
and in some cases, even some
of the cognitive impairment.
And so I'll end with
this sort of positive,
on sort of hopeful last slide.
This suggests that maybe by understanding
detailed mechanisms by which complement
and microglia are selectively
targeting synapses
in these various models,
could this help us to try to identify
new targets to particularly
manipulate synapse loss
in the right time in the right place?
And could it also identify new biomarkers
for some of these disorders?
So I'll just end there by
thanking a lot of individuals,
past and present lab members,
incredible collaborators and
of course generous funding.
Thanks so much.
(applause)
(calm music)